-Our next guest is
an Emmy Award-winning
and Tony-nominated actor
you know from his work
in "Bridesmaids," "Moone Boy,"
and "The IT Crowd."
He stars in
"The Big Door Prize,"
which premieres tomorrow
on Apple TV+.
Let's take a look.
-Believe it or not,
for the two bucks
you saved on coffee,
that thing will tell you
your life's potential.
-Is that right? [ Chuckles ]
Where'd you get it?
-No idea.
Jacob was manning the store
when it arrived on Friday,
but a lot of people
used it over the weekend
and, uh, seems to be good
for business,
so I'm not asking questions.
-[ Chuckles ]
-Please welcome back to the show
Chris O'Dowd, everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Welcome back! It's been a while.
-I know. It's been
like five years or something.
-Five years.
I'm thrilled to have you back.
This is a wonderful show
that's based on a book
of the same name.
A machine,
as we saw in the clip,
arrives in a small town.
Lay out the premise
for us a little bit.
-That's it.
Like, I play a...
what do you call it?
A high school history teacher
called Dusty.
Very settled, very happy
kind of implant
from Ireland, maybe 20 years.
But now this chapter
in his life,
he's married, he's got a kid.
He thinks he has it sorted.
This machine arrives
in a local kind of grocery store
with the promise
of telling everybody
what their true life
potential is.
So, you kind of sit
into the machine
and it takes your fingerprints
and your Social Security number,
at which point I'm out, right?
I'm out.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-But this idiot...
And then it takes
a few more details about you,
and everybody
in the course of the story
and every -- all of
the inhabitants of this town
start getting these cards with,
like, whatever --
karate teacher or whatnot --
and it starts changing
the course of their lives.
Like, the school principal gets
"biker" and she gets a bike.
And so it's this kind of idea
that the collective delusion
that if you want the oracle
to give you information,
then it will
and you can follow it as much
or as little as you want to,
like a football team
or a religion or -- or whatnot.
And so we see
all of these people.
This catalyst is kind of used
for everybody
to change their lives.
-And were you drawn
to the mysticism of this idea?
-I've been here in America
for a while
and I see people chasing
a lot of pretty crazy ideas.
-[ Chuckles ] Yeah.
-Just because
somebody says it might be fun
and then
there's an insurrection.
So I...
[ Laughter ]
So I did...
Which I'm sure was
its own fun on the day.
-I think on the day.
We do forget that they were all
with a lot of like-minded people
having a grand old time.
-And I suppose that doesn't
happen in this town yet.
But essentially what does happen
is that people change
the relationships.
People feel different
about themselves.
And it does offer the premise
that even though the book
was written
before the pandemic,
it's got a reset kind of feel to
it where it's like if you're --
if you think you're not
doing life right, sure,
just give it another whirl.
-[ Chuckles ] Did you --
One thing in the clip,
we didn't fully see it,
but I know you got
a scooter in this.
You got to ride
a scooter around.
Now, I would...
I would not --
I'd be worried about that
if I, as a performer,
had to get on a scooter.
Are you somebody who's good
at those sort of things?
-I've been on a paddle board.
If you've ever been
on a paddle board?
-I have. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-Didn't go great, you know?
And the scooter was okay.
I don't have the center of a --
center of balance right
for a scooter,
but after a while,
just the gravity does it alone.
It's kind of --
It's hard to fall off.
Just like,
as if you put a boulder
on a scooter and pushed it down.
[ Laughter ]
But, yeah,
I get some moves out.
It's -- It's very...
-[ Laughs ]
-It's very, very sexy.
-Oh, wow.
-Yeah. I want people
to be prepared for that.
-Do you think it's sexy
for everyone,
or do you think you just have
the right kind of body
to be sexy on a scooter?
-I think that -- yes.
Because I suppose
it's the -- it's the contrast
with the kind
of the narrowness of...
That was a mistake.
[ Laughter ]
I'm going to regret that
down the road.
-Eh, we're gonna...
We could edit it out
or leave it in, I feel like.
[ Laughter ]
-But, yeah, I got
to do some scootering.
I got to do some dancing,
which is fun.
I get out all my skills, use six
of my faces.
It's a whole thing.
-Did you --
When you were a kid,
did you do any of
the sort of fortune teller stuff
like Magic Eight Ball
or Ouija board or any of those?
-We did some Ouija boards.
And this is kind of like that.
It's kind of like a Zoltar type
of machine, and then it can...
But I don't know
if I would do it now.
I feel a bit untethered now
that I would be like...
For example, it was my kid's
birthday a couple of weeks ago
and we got a magician.
He's mad into magic.
And the magician said
that his wife was a palm reader
and she could come
and do the adults
while everybody else was...
And so she came.
Her name was Miss Zelda.
I don't know if
it's her real name.
-Yeah. And it seems pretty
fortuitous if that's it.
-Maybe that's one
of those things
where it's a self-fulfilling
thing.
-Right. Like, if you're --
if you're a Zelda and you go --
-She's not going to work in
insurance.
-Right, exactly.
-But anyway,
I didn't go to the lady
because I felt like I don't know
if I could deal with the --
maybe she's right.
I don't want her to be right.
I just don't want
anything useful to happen.
-I -- Yeah. I don't want
to know the future.
-Right.
-Yeah. Mostly because
I feel like, good or bad,
if I get the information,
I would somehow screw it up.
-That's what I would do with
this machine where it's like,
I think I do it just because
everybody was doing it.
But I wouldn't want
anybody to know
what was on my card
because I don't
want next week for some [bleep]
to be like,
"Are you an astronaut yet?"
No, I'm not. I'm not.
I have napped.
[ Laughter ]
-You play a high school teacher,
as you mentioned.
Do you think that's something
that would fit your skill set?
Would you have liked that
as a path?
-I think it's an incredible job.
I don't know
if I have the patience for it.
My sister is a teacher,
but I don't...
I could --
I could be a professor.
-Oh, interesting. What is
your distinction of the two?
-Well, that's step two
that we haven't got to yet.
But if there was anything
that I had some kind of in-depth
knowledge in, it would be --
it would be...
I don't know if I could deal
with kids all the time.
-Yeah.
-They're so stupid.
[ Laughter ]
By the way, I'm so...
You did a wonderful show.
The first time
you were on the show
was for this wonderful show
called "Moone Boy."
-Yes.
-And I remember you were here,
and that was like 2014.
And I always remember
one of the things you said,
this was before I even had kids,
you said, you know,
the thing about kids
is they're so stupid.
-[ Laughs ]
-And now I got them
and you got them.
And I want you to know,
I'm saying this
with all authenticity,
I think about you all the time.
-[ Laughs ]
-Like when I --
Because I know it's you, too.
Because when my kids
are misbehaving,
I think in my head,
"You're so stupid."
And it's in an Irish accent.
-Good.
I got to tell you,
a quick kid story
because this happened
a couple of weeks ago.
So, I was -- I was -- I think
I was making breakfast
or something,
and there's like a toilet
somewhere downstairs.
And my kid was on --
my six-year-old
was sitting on the toilet.
And so we just have
a conversation.
And so he's just, "Daddy!
What if people
didn't have phones?"
And I was like, "Well, you know,
people didn't
always have phones."
And he said, "What?!"
And I said --
We're in different rooms.
And I said,
"Well, when Daddy was young,
we didn't have
any mobile phones."
And then there was
this long pause.
And then he said,
"I said bones!"
[ Laughter ]
And what I realized, though,
there was -- there was
a good eight seconds there
where he thought
when I was young there was...
[ Laughter ]
-I also like...
-Like jellyfish people.
-Yeah. You had --
You had sitting bones,
but no mobile bones.
-[ Laughs ]
-You could stay in one place
with your bones,
but they wouldn't go anywhere.
-Half man, half chair.
-[ Laughs ]
What a delight
to have you back here.
Thanks so much for joining us.
-Thank you.
-So great to see you.
-Chris O'Dowd, everybody.
"The Big Door Prize" premieres
Wednesday on Apple TV+.
We'll be right back
with more "Late Night."